hey everyone it's Mike from motlow here
and welcome back to my channel you know
it's been a while since I've posted a
video it's uh the start of 20125 and you
know sort of one of my New Year's
resolutions is to get uh more content
out to you guys on a regular basis so be
sure to subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and hit that
notification Bell so that whenever I
post a new video you'll be notified of
it so you know what I want to talk about
today is um you know when markets move
very fast in a short period of time you
know you often get these reversals like
you could see here right reversed here
uh reversed here you know what is it in
the order flow is there anything in
there that can give you Clues as to a
potential reversal about to take place
because you know we just made a new high
here and then uh we started selling off
you know you got your first leg down you
pull back and then you start selling off
but then you reverse right here you go
up pull back go up pull back make a run
up to this High then you reverse off
this you know is there anything in the
order flow that could potentially clue
you into a reversal now you know
sometimes people think that order flow
is going to give you every single Market
turn in the market you know honestly I
wish it was that simple but sometimes
you know there's different things
happening in the order flow and there's
something that I call an imbalance
reversal that I've talked about for for
you know a long time you know over a
decade um it was actually one of the
first tools that we put in the
orderflows trader software the footprint
software um to to spot these reversals
and you know in the old days I just used
to sit back watch watch a footprint
chart looking for something to happen
and then trade off of it all right so
you know this is your basic footprint
chart now this is the orderflows trader
software that um I developed and this is
just a basic uh volume footprint you
know bid volume offer volume and point
of control as well as your Delta numbers
on the bottom now sometimes you know
getting to what an imbalance reversal is
well it's the result of a market that
moves too fast in Too Short a time
period And it basically becomes
overextended and when that happens you
often get a nice little short-term
reversal all right so let's just go back
to some of these um quick reversals all
right so here's the first one right we
just we made a new high made a new high
made a new high start coming off we pull
back up here and then we start selling
off but when we get down here the market
reverses right and then you get this
nice big green um up bar you know with a
lot of thin volume as the market is
reversing up now what caused is an
imbalance reversal well it could be seen
in a footprint chart um when you have a
red candle after a move or a green
candle after a move but more importantly
what you want to see is on a green
candle if you're looking for this Market
to reverse what you want to see is
selling imbalances towards the bottom of
the bar okay um what's happening is the
Market's running into
liquidity and at the same time the
aggressive trading is drying up right
because you know as the Market's coming
down you can see we're coming through
liquidity here we get 31 256
1622 uh Market pulls back up starts
coming back down taking out this little
swing low here 26 17 25 26 comes down
here meets more liquidity 30 32 44 16 12
12 14 21 but what is the obvious thing
that sticks out here well you've got
selling imbalances here okay and the
candle's green so you got to be thinking
okay I got selling imbalances which is
bearish order flow right because you
have aggressive sellers selling into
passive buyers right you can see on this
move down here right selling the
balances two in this bar one here one
two three here one here um got another
three here but then in this one you got
two and the market reversed so you have
a combination of the market running into
liquidity and the last sellers selling
okay you even got a little tail uh U
order flow tail taking place here with
the 0 so the market pushes down here and
then the selling just sort of shuts off
right the last seller has sold the
market starts reversing that is
something that you can trade right now
obviously you want to see the follow
through orderflow in the next bar and
then you get it really strong in the
next bar this Market you know as soon as
this bar closes next Bar opens up 76 uh
you know where we opened up we open 7640
and immediately trade up you know
basically three bucks to
7920 and the next bar um it goes even
higher right so that's a quick move from
um you know 7660 all the way up to 81
you know 40 so it's about a$ four and a
half dollar move right there very quick
right and this Market just became
overextended it left that footprint
quote unquote in the footprint so to
speak in in the market reversed right
then we started going back back up then
we go sideways here
okay then we get up here right this is
our this green line is our high of the
day and we're pushing up near the high
and you have sort of the same thing
taking place you got buying
imbalances I say same thing but in the
opposite direction you got buying IM
balances in this red bar so you know
Traders were very optimistic that hey
we're going to take out this high at uh
8390 see a couple buying and balances
here um top of this green bar you got
some more buying and balances we do pull
back back a little bit but the bar is
still green so it's still bullish in a
sense um price action is still moving
higher we go out we take out those highs
of this buying and balance here then we
get up here we get within you know two
ticks of the
high where's your buying it's gone right
I mean is is it strong liquidity up here
no you know it's 6 10 19 so it's not
like it's 110 and 190 but it's still you
know it is still a buying and balance
bance in the red candle market closes
down in the bar right and then we get
this nice little move lower right we we
trade from you know the low of this bar
what is that 8240 we get all the way
down to you know 80 right here and then
even further down to
7930 so you had a nice um was that $3
move right there uh then we start going
sideways and eventually we do go a
little bit lower but
on our footprint chart right we do make
it easier this like I said you know I
developed this orderflows Trader
software um to help me see these things
taking place in the order flow we call
this an imbalance reversal right here so
to enable it you just click there you
could use a swing filter which I'll get
into a minute and there's something
that's called the minimum minimal
imbalance reversal volume I I keep it
set at 10 because you know I want to
make sure that the imbalance is I don't
say legit but you know meet a certain
minimum volume requirement you know
because you could have an imbalance of
you know 4 to one where you have one
contract against five and yeah that is a
that is an imbalance but you know it's
kind of light volume okay so that's why
I have it set at 10 then you just click
apply okay what's going to do it's going
to highlight
it here this is
a bullish imbalance reversal that's the
green you can see here the 13 and the 13
get this little pop up here's the
bearish one that I just talked about
earlier you do get one here but again
you know imbalance reversal you want to
move to have taken place to reverse
right if you if you're just coming off
from you know 8240 then you hit
8170 that that's not a move that's going
to
reverse um yeah you got one here there's
a bearish one right here so again you
know remember the this is where Traders
get mixed up is because they start to
look at all instances of red bars with
buying imbalances in near the top or
selling imbalances in green candles near
the bottom and that's not what you're
supposed to be looking for remember
right you're you're looking for the
market to reverse so for a market to
reverse you have to have a move take
place okay
and you know you could have a swing
filter right we've added something
that's called a swing filter um you can
see it right here swing period is going
to be set to five that's my default that
I use but to enable it if you just want
to see it on swings you click there
right enable swing filter and it's just
going to filter out when they occur in
swings that's why this buy is gone right
because it's not just oh there's a
selling imbalance at the bottom of a
green candle I got to take it no right
you want to have a move to have happened
now this one is debatable because it's
not coming in on a swing low so that's
why it's not showing but if
you know as a Trader you got to make
decisions I know everyone likes to
automate everything and you know you
could automate it in the future say
swing low plus one bar okay but really
what I like to see them on is moves that
happen where the market gets
overextended and then it just leaves
this sort of obvious footprint in the
chart of what's taking place in the
market okay now let's take a look at
another Market here it's going to be a
little a bit more clear okay so this is
crude oil right you got one just taking
place right now as I'm recording this
video right on the low of the day okay
you think that's important of course it
is right it's the low of the day you've
got aggressive selling taking place down
into the low you make the new low then
you start reversing up and going higher
okay let's see if there's any others now
again here's a low start moving up now
remember it's called an imbalance
reversal it's not called the imbalance
momentum um so that's why I like to use
the swing f filter right because yeah
while this one didn't go a little higher
this one you know went two ticks higher
you know you would have been stopped out
that's why you know I advocate using a
swing filter right you don't want to say
oh I'm going to take this because it's
got the selling imbalance there on the
green candle I got to take it right or
you know take this short or take this
short again you know you just made a new
low of the day and you've got here you
got a bullish imbalance reversal a
bearish imbalance reversal on the
surface right just on the footprint
chart with the buying imbalance at at
the top selling a balance at the bottom
which one do you want to take you don't
want to be getting short necessarily
into a low I I think the best trades to
take are Longs off of the low right so
what you do right clean it up is you use
the swing
filter okay now again you could use
whatever swings you want you know five
is sort of my default you could use 10
you could use whatever number that that
you're comfortable with um you know some
people I know use 25 right then you just
click enable uh swing filter
here okay so you see right here right
there's your bullish one um obviously
that one on the low that we just made is
still is going to show because that's
the new low
um see anymore here's a nice bearish one
okay right you see here this is coming
in around the
74 this appears at 7460 right we trade
all the way back up to that price level
and then we you know come off start
making new lows but uh let's see if
there's anything else you know here's
another bearish one come right back up
to that level start selling
off okay there's one yeah just didn't
work
out that great but I mean that's how it
is sometimes right but ideally you know
you want to find them at swing highs or
swing lows as opposed to just anywhere
on your chart okay and
yeah I don't need to go back so far but
you can see how this one is playing out
right now as this video is being
recorded So anyway guys you know that is
the whole concept of imbalance reversals
it's a great little setup um you can use
it in every market and you know it again
you know it's something that when I
first started trading with orderflow
that's something I just looked for right
I just focused on that taking place in
the market you know so whether you're
using my orderflows Trader software
which in my opinion makes it much easier
to see or just using a plain old
footprint that's what you want to see in
the order flow right that's something
that you can do you can use you can
trade um in any market so if you enjoy
this video be sure to subscribe to the
channel hit the like button um you know
leave a comment in the comments below as
well if uh you got some value out of it
all right everybody take care